I've got sense from the moment she's
born a man's daughter is the center of
his universe you give her love you give
her encouragement you watch her grow
into a strong confident woman and then
one day you come face to face with the
love of her life mother [ __ ]
Fleming's are in the house yes oh my god
[ __ ] yeah looks like he works out quite
a bad step you get him up here
please cookies turns out her boyfriend
is this internet billionaire
I'm so [ __ ] psyched to drive here for
the holidays it's a 15 year old child
you don't say [ __ ] ah kid clared has
literally no filter but he's a really
good guy remember when we made love in
the hospital staff opened up like a
flower you should have seen it I
shouldn't have seen it but now I feel
like I have no father would want their
daughter with this guy my instinct is to
hug you right now good night
I don't know what his issues are oh my
oh ma I feel like I'm so normal a little
surprised uh-uh
sent our Christmas card it's all you it
says Happy Holidays and everything says
Happy Holidays oh [ __ ] I didn't know
he'd put happy holidays on there
I guess that's on me forever now dead
Christmas Day I'm gonna ask Stephie to
marry me and I'd really like it blessing
yeah yeah but just give me a couple days
when you over by Christmas morning
you're gonna be calling me son how many
calling you dad don't think that's gonna
happen I think it's gonna dad I know it
won't dad it was not that blood dad that
that stop that dad what are you talking
about yes siree Bob you could be dating
anyone while Eric he makes me really
happy
that kid is wrapping his tentacles
around every member of his family
because of his influence your mother
smoking marijuana
this is not someone we want our daughter
marrying I am gonna take this octopus
down you're gonna say anything that
Stephanie about to proposal right Drella
Laird is spying on us wait do not mess
with me I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really brown
there you are